لم يالفوا حوارات تدور حول قصف وقذائف
تضرب عاصمه بلادهم بخور القهوه الذي
يشاركهم الحديث يذكرهم بالدخان المتصاعد
من ابنيه الخرطوم هكذا انقلبت احوال
الجاليه السودانيه في الرياض من حديث عن
هموم الغربه الى قلق على الوطن
الاوضع سيئه بالنسبه لنا
هنا وكده فالواحد يعني حزين لكن نسال الله
انه ربنا يسهل الامور ويرفع البلاء عن
العباد والبلاد ان شاء الله لحتى ما قدرنا
نعيد على عيالنا فهمت علي انه الواحد ما
قدر يصل لعياله عن طريق تليفون ولا عن
طريق اي برامج من برامج التواصل الاجتماعي
في الاماكن العامه والاماكن الخاصه يشترك
سودانيون في هذه الايام بالحديث عن الحرب
ولا غير الحرب حديث لم يعتادوا عليه طوال
العقود الماضيه لكنهم قلقون مما يحدث في
الداخل لسيما وان اهاليهم واصدقائهم لا
زالوا في مدن تضربها النيران
كلما طرفت عيني يرف ضياء في
اذا خطرت احس بالموج فوق البحر يلعب
مواساه قد تنطق بها ابيات شعريه وتعبر
عنها نظرات الحضور هنا مشهد القريه حاضر
في صلب الاحاديث اخرون يتسمرون امام
الشاشات بحثا عن نهايه لهذا الكابوس
اعتادوا على التكافل الاجتماعي في
جمعياتهم وتقديم الدعم للمغتربين الجدد
لكنهم شرعوا هذه المره في محاوله تقديم
الدعم المادي لقريتهم في شمال السودان
لمساعده اهاليهم الذين نزحوا من الخرطوم
هربا من الحرب
الان في الخرطوم كل التجاره متوقفه يعني
في اي لحظه اذا استمر
الكيلاج ده لمده شهر حتحصل مجاعه داخل
الخرطوم ناس بالذات المغتربين الموجودين
هنا الكاتبهم هناك ويعني قدروا يعملوا نوع
من النفير على اساس انه يساعدوا الاسره
العالقه ما قادره ما عندها امكانيه توصل
لاهلها في الشمال الناس يتعاون كل الجمعيه
في حدود اهلها علق الكثير من المغتربين
السودانيين المقيمين في السعوديه في بدايه
الحرب بالخرطوم بعضهم استطاع العوده من
خلال سفن الاجلاء السعودي
فيما يخطط الكثير ممن التقيناهم هنا لجلب
عائلاتهم الى السعوديه في حال استمرار
الحرب عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه
الرياض لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات